et pour faire face à la crise économique
la france souhaite que le pacte de
stabilité européen soit suspendue l'an
prochain souhait émis hier par bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie qui
voudrait que les règles de discipline
budgétaire entre les états membres de
l'union européenne soit suspendue pour
2020 et aussi pour 2021
le 20 mars dernier bruxelles avait
suspendu cette règle des 3% il mesure
inédite dans l'union européenne
voyez ce qu'en dit florian philippot
président des patriotes et partisan de
la sortie de la france de l'union
européenne celle que si on appliquer le
pacte de stabilité de toute façon on
mourait donc je crois qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup de choix
ce sont des critères de d'austérité si
on applique l'austérité maintenant on
meurt tout simplement
donc moi je constate quand même il faut
quand même le noter l que l'union
européenne elle fait de bonnes choses en
fait quand elle annule ses propres
politiques
1 c'est quand même à noter la seule
chose qu'on lui demande en fait c'est de
ne pas intervenir et de d'annuler ses
propres politiques comme on doit le
faire sur le pacte de stabilité
mais ce pas que la qualité faut pas
simplement le jeu les en 2020 et en 2021
il faut s'en débarrasser une bonne fois
pour toutes
j'irai même beaucoup plus loin il faut
que nous sortions clairement de l'union
européenne et de l'euro parce que si on
veut avoir une seule petite chance de
réindustrialiser la france est de faire
du patriotisme économique ce qui va être
indispensable si on veut survivre face à
la crise gigantesque qui arrive on
pourra pas le faire dans le cadre de
l'union européenne l'union peine d'être
une machine à nous affaiblir
elle n'est pas une machine à nous
renforcer